Minnesota's just announced it will give
free college education to illegal aliens
this is being touted as a way to quote
provide historic investment for student
support and our institutions there are
going to be a lot of people who have
paid for College in Minnesota who are
going to be furious about this people
who are American citizens Minnesota
taxpayers they had to pay for their
education meanwhile these illegal aliens
come in they break our laws and they get
free education this isn't fair yeah
you're right it's not fair why would the
state do this the state would do this
because public education is not
primarily about the individual public
education is primarily about the state
the state of Minnesota a liberal people
who rule Minnesota are not doing this
because they really care for the
well-being of the Venezuelan migrants or
I guess more likely Somalian migrants
into Minnesota the liberal rulers of
Minnesota are doing this because they
know that forcing these people into
classrooms will shape their minds and
impel them to conform to the liberal
ideology that governs the state